when a laser emits beams of light
particles called photons at a screen
with two slits you'd expect to see two
strips to correspond with the two slits
instead we see a pattern of light and
dark bands this suggests that light
behaves like waves that pass through
both slits simultaneously interfering
with each other to create the pattern on
the second screen however when
scientists used a measuring device to
observe this slit that each Photon
passed through the interference pattern
disappeared and two strips appeared the
act of observing which slit it went
through changed the behavior of the
photons no one knows why observing a
particle causes Its Behavior to change